dear fellow scholars this is two minute
papers with károly on a affair this
piece of work enables us to walk around
in a room with a camera and create a
complete 3d computer model from the
video footage the technique has a really
cool effect where the 3d model is
continuously refined as we obtain more
and more data by walking around with our
camera this is a very difficult problem
and the good solution to this offers a
set of cool potential applications if we
have a 3d model of a scene what can we
do with it well of course assign
different materials to them and run a
light simulation program for
architectural visualization applications
animation movies and so on we can also
easily scan a lot of different
furnitures and create a useful database
out of them there are tons of more
applications but I think these should do
for starters normally if one has to
create a 3d model of a room or a
building the bottom line is that it
requires several days or weeks of labor
fortunately with this technique we'll
obtain a 3d model in real time and we
won't have to go through these
tribulations however I'd like to note
that the models are still by far not
perfect if we are interested in the many
small intricate details we have to add
them back by hand previous methods were
able to achieve similar results but they
suffer from a number of different
drawbacks for instance most of them
don't support traditional consumer
cameras or take minutes to hours to
perform the reconstruction to produce
the results presented in the paper an
nvidia titan x video card was used which
is currently one of the pricier pieces
of equipment for consumers but not so
much for companies who are typically
interested in these applications if we
take into consideration the rate at
which graphical Hardware is improving
anyone will be able to run this at home
in real time in a few years time the
comparisons to previous works reveal
that this technique is not only real
time but the quality of the results is
mostly comparable and in some cases it
surpasses previous methods thanks for
watching and for your generous support
and I'll see you next time
you